something's just not working and then it
just clicked I was I was done and it was
it felt like a really long breakup and I
was like oh my god now I'm free the
shackles have been removed
you initially wanted to be a
screenwriter yeah I initially went to
college in Arizona and studied
screenwriting read all the books wrote a
couple of screenplays never had anything
made and then came out to Los Angeles
took some UCLA extension courses on
screenwriting and I was like that
somehow I think I tricked myself into
saying that I was gonna be an actor and
so I went full-on into that whole actor
world and doing the you know
nine-to-five waiting tables and then
going to auditions when I could or
classes at night and you know scene
study and paying for coaches and all
that kind of thing it was all under the
illusion of storytelling of like I
wanted to just create and so I spent 10
years doing that and and then realized
that I didn't need to nail it as an
actor in order for me to go back to
storytelling I could just story tell so
he's kind of full circle started out as
screenwriting then into acting and then
into YouTube and now it's like a blend
it's a mishmash of everything together
so this is a personal question you don't
have to answer but did you ever make
more acting than you did at the waiting
tables job I know you can make a lot
waiting table so no no I made my
experience act I'll tell you the thing
that kind of made me turn the tables on
whether or not I wanted to continue
pursuing acting at this point I was 10
years down the rabbit hole and so I'm
just throwing good money after bad and I
haven't had that much success I've been
a couple short films been in a couple
movies been on a TV show in terms of
like how much money and time and effort
that I spent going headfirst into this
really challenging and competitive
career filled there was not a lot of
feedback that was telling me to keep
going and I think the straw that broke
the camel's back was we ended up
producing our own film we wrote we shot
it we edited it we produced it with a
couple
other actor friends of ours and it was
the most extensive amount of time that I
had spent acting actually perfecting my
craft and actually performing when I'm
not in class or you know doing like
little plays or whatever in
Hollywood
it was the most amount of time that I
actually was doing the thing that I
wanted to do not just practicing to do
it or the auditioning thing and that
just broke my heart I was like wow the I
have spent so much money in time and
effort and just willpower trying to do
this thing that like it's not responding
to me at all and it's been ten years and
the most experience that I have is
something that I produce myself like
something's something's just not working
and then it just clicked I was I was
done and it was it felt like a really
long break up and I was like oh my god
now I'm free the shackles have been
removed I I can go do whatever it is
that I want to do I don't have to be an
actor I don't have to do interviews and
and try to sell movies and I mean that's
time of the thing audition I didn't have
to audition anymore right I didn't have
to prove myself to go be in a role I
could just go create the role and you
were working as a waiter at the time
yeah so I spent about five years at one
restaurant and another three years and
another one and so I'd been in the
restaurant industry for about ten years
you know waiting for that that role to
come around that producer or that
director I mean that the whole that
whole stereotype is so true I mean you
literally are waiting on other people to
live your life for you and I just got
tired of it
you